ce terrain vague de sept hectares
pourrait se transformer en stadium de
bmx dans les prochaines années l'île des
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines a
été retenue dans le dossier paris 2024
pour accueillir les épreuves masculines
et féminines de ce sport extrême
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jouent ce jeu le vélodrome
on est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite qu'on peut
leur complémentarité entre les épreuves
qui se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et
les épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du
cadre nature qui s'y prête parfaitement
exit donc l'actuel stadium de bmx situé
à côté du vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le parcours n'est pas aux normes
olympiques autre point noir le toit
la structure métallique peut gêner la
télévision pour les plans aériens
le stadium servira donc de piste
d'entraînement les athlètes pourront
s'échauffer sur la piste de bmx actuelle
avant de venir concourir ici et c'est
vraiment tout ça je vous dis encore une
fois dans un environnement de d'une
centaine de mètres donc tout pourra se
faire à pied sans problème pour
correspondre cette fois ci au cahier des
charges olympique le nouveau site aura
une piste provisoire comprise entre 400
et 450 m les tribunes devront également
pouvoir accueillir plusieurs milliers de
personnes
d'importants travaux sont donc à prévoir
c'est du comité olympique qui va
exactement définir les surfaces non ils
ont besoin notamment des places de
parking parce que comme on espère
beaucoup beaucoup de visiteurs il faudra
des places de parking il y en a déjà
mais c'est pas suffisant
donc voilà c'est tout à fait un gros
projet quand même puisqu'il va sortir de
terre cette future piste est accueilli
comme une bonne nouvelle par l'équipe de
france de bmx médaillés d'or et d'argent
aux jo de 2008
pour les bleus c'est 2 stadium seront un
plus dans la quête de nouveaux titres
olympiques en 2024 pour l'entraînement
ça représente
après deux superbes outils sur lesquels
on peut diversifier justement les
entraînements ce qui peut les aider à
progresser encore un petit peu plus
maintenant sur le fait voilà de la
compet de la faire sur une autre piste
une façon ils seront prêts quoi qu'il
arrive donc que ce soit sur celle là ou
sur une autre encore une fois le job
sera le même si la france est retenue
par le comité olympique en septembre les
premières consultations seront lancés
d'ici la fin de l'année et travaux
pourraient eux débuter d'ici 2020